you know this is why the score doesn't
sit right in my spirit
okay because i just don't understand why
people can't understand the significance
of coming to america but i think most
importantly
i think people were like waiting for
eddie murphy to carry the entire film
and that's why coming to america works
because it's about his interactions with
everyone else
that he's coming in contact with because
they have such an amazing
cast of comedians and people that you
know later down the road became very
famous
but i think most importantly it was a
movie that showed us that
you know i understand what we go through
in america but outside of that like
black people are royalty like we're
royal we have jobs
we have money like we create our own
businesses
i just think for me i just remember
looking at lisa like oh my goodness like
lisa is like running this whole business
and like i can do that too so it just
had a different impact for me as a child
watching coming to america yeah and i
guess that kind of gets to like
the main sort of like reason why
like you know when i kind of like go
back to like why i love this movie
um it kind of hits into some of the
stuff it you said but like sum it up for
me
uh quickly why is this movie give me
like one line on why
it is awesome and everyone should check
it out everyone should celebrate it or
why and particularly why you
love it it's like watching a black
family reunion
that you just see your family in the
movie from the preacher to the sister
to just everyone that's that's how i
feel it's a black family reunion
i i really love that answer because it's
so true
we'll get into that a bit on the fun
facts what about you mark
uh if i had to do one word i would
actually just say barbershop can be one
word right
yeah i can't i guess barbershop can be
one word
sexual chocolate you're really pushing
it with just one word but
i actually love what what sharonda said
about
this is eddie murphy and his
interactions with other people
because up to this point everybody's new
eddie murphy is a high-energy
comedian in movies and this was the
first time he stepped out of that box so
i actually appreciate getting to see
eddie murphy
and his range not just with the
different characters he's playing
but with prince hakeem and how he
doesn't have to be
the same cookie cutter character that we
already knew him to be
he can branch out yeah because the
keem's like
keem's doing some like steve arkell
steve urkel stuff you know what i mean
he's very much doing the like i'm gonna
do the suave
stuff and then i'm gonna also be really
a goof on the other side it just kind of
it kind of is nice how that character is
able to balance that
for me though like the reason why i love
this movie on top of it's funny on top
i love watching eddie murphy do anything
and it has so many people who
become like basically almost family
members given up how many movies you
kind of saw with them
um it did something that even the people
involved didn't know that they did it
until after it came out
and i really do love when movies have
that kind of like singular moment where
it's like
you guys really did that you guys
created something that was going to be a
beacon
of sort of like aspirational um versions
of what
black royalty could be to what black
people could be without colonialism and
we saw that come to fruition later
with a movie like black panther but this
was that first sort of like
taste of that and i think that's why we
maybe yearned for it so much by the time
we got to black panther
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you